la guerra trajo muchos retos para cada
una de las provincias ucranianas una de
ellas era cómo encontrar esos chalecos y
esos uniformes para proteger no
solamente al ejército sino también a sus
defensores territoriales personas que se
unieron en la defensa de las ciudades y
de las provincias esta era una fábrica
de ropa hasta el comienzo de la guerra y
por iniciativa del comité militar pasó a
ser por ejemplo chalecos antibalas o
también uniformes militares aquí en este
momento hay 40 mujeres la mayoría de
ellas son desplazadas internas que
vienen de otros lugares de ucrania que
trabajan en este momento en la
fabricación por ejemplo de estos
chalecos todo ha sido un reto conseguir
la en la tela conseguir el material que
va adentro y también esas placas con las
cuales los chalecos se protegen esta es
una ciudad industrial pero especialmente
con unas grandes minas y también
metalúrgica lo que les ha ayudado a
hacer unas placas especiales que han
tenido que probar una manera un poco
rudimentaria pues no tienen todos los
laboratorios pero hasta el momento les
apuntó y al día de hoy producen chalecos
como éste que son los que utilizan sus
fuerzas especiales los hombres que
protegen la ciudad en esta ciudad de
kribi ri de donde es originario el
presidente vladimir sales